cnbc said this which i want to just add
this at the end of it higher home prices
and rates have crushed home
affordability for instance on a 400 000
home with a 20
down payment the monthly mortgage
payment you ready the monthly mortgage
payment went from 13.99 in the start of
january which is only five months ago to
1976.
guys this is america let me say that one
more time on a 400 000 property with a
20 down payment which is what 80 grand
on a 320 loan your payment went from
13.99
five months ago tyler
to 1976 not in a year not in two years
in five months and you're not buying a
two million dollar home you buying a 400
000 house with a 20 20 down payment
that's 80 percent of america by the way
and patrick you and remember we talked
about this when uh when brian when
callum was here so what when people are
saying in a year 18 months it's all
gonna change what what what does it take
for something that keeps going up it
keeps going higher i know people talk
about a bubble and all that stuff i i
don't even know what the hell that means
but what people were like
echo you guys are talking i felt like my
head was going to pop off
but uh
because i'm that person that's you know
hustling and you know and doing their
thing and like you guys talk about the
policies it's like the writing's on the
wall trump i'm not sticking up for the
guy but he said everything that was
going to happen i just saw a
instagram clip before i came in here
everything that he said was going to
happen you know the the second amendment
you know prices gas this everything that
this guy said is happening and what
trips me out the most is i have a lot of
you know liberal friends and my cousins
are hardcore liberals but like the
people left it's like nothing it's all
good for them nothing and that's why
y'all talk all the [ __ ] you want about
the left and these hardcore uh liberals
they stay the course and they go down
with the [ __ ] they don't give a [ __ ]
bro you know what the left reminds me of
remember in titanic when the the glacier
ever they're [ __ ] gonna die and the
violin and the people are doing that
that's the left the left is like we
don't give a [ __ ] gas yeah that formula
we're [ __ ] staying on the ball but
that's a problem they're going to give a
[ __ ] in in
midterms
we don't want to say we told you but the
writing is on the like
well let me tell you they did i'll tell
you why they did care because a lot of
them a lot of those liberals got up and
they left new york city and los angeles
they live here now yeah so they cared
enough when it impacted their own pocket
that doesn't mean that's going to change
how they vote because there's a loyalty
to the cause there's a loyalty even if
the cause is burying you the cause could
have the shovel with the dirt and just
putting it on top you're buried alive
and you're buried alive but the cause
has to win but it'll change where they
go because they're like well i can't pay
those that's why pat talks about uh the
10 that run america are in the middle
swing voters oh yeah look the reality is
there's two you know what team you're
voting for for the most part you already
know who you're gonna vote for in 2024.
you don't even know who's running but
you know who you're voting oh yeah it
could be the it could be jimbo it could
be his dog i'm voting for the dog i'm
dead that's
but the point is there's gonna there's
ten percent that's saying
i don't know let's see who knows i'm in
the midwest i'm in toledo ohio i'm in
youngstown ohio i'm in detroit michigan
i'm in des moines iowa these people who
are who run the country it's not the
liberal in california yeah and it's not
the yeah you don't think what i don't
even know if it's ten i don't even know
if there's that many people undecided at
this point i really don't i think
underworld numbers
i think it's like slim to none honestly
i really do because i think i really
there's people who are looking at this
and they're like
i i can't go along with this maybe they
voted for maybe there were republicans
who voted there were republicans who
just many you mean all the riots there's
many people i'm gonna endorse this what
what has played out with the mass on the
kids
if whoever runs for the democratic wins
i'm gonna call cheating right now that's
it i'm gonna call it this
or was it 10 thousand mules or did you
guys see that the documentary by two
thousand million two thousand mules
whatever
have you seen it
had a january segment people people that
i did see that said that they saw it
they were shocked that well maybe you've
gotta see it to have feedback on it
we'll we'll we'll see it and we'll have
feedback on it but you know to to go
back to what you were talking about with
the with the voting side the 10 percent
uh and what happens these next six
months if this thing gets worse and
worse and worse
listen when when the left turns on the
left
it's over the writing's on the when
obama and michelle are out campaigning
right now to save their party you know
something's going on
when obama and michelle are out that's
when stuff is really going up because
they're like no no no no we're not
biting no no no no we're not this
there's rumors right now that susan rice
is running america and nobody even knows
about it and susan rice is right
actually american
rights
obama's running america through susan
rice
uh but do you have a problem with that
by the way i i am not a no as far as
being an american do you have a problem
with that i will listen first of all
this is gonna sound very strange i would
much rather have an obama over biden
okay
i would much rather have an obama over
biden and a zero percent and if a person
in the middle of the right can't say
that you are you are part of the problem
because at least obama could come out at
a time like this and give a message and
calm the nerves and we could move out
right biden can't even do that at least
obama could come out and give a message
where people are not crazy overreacting
he was poised to give a message like
that but biden went on jimmy kimmel the
other day i was watching i'm like jimmy
cut him off
cut him off this is bad for america for
him to be shown that way finally jimmy's
like i think it's
we got to go to break and we'll come
back he's like yeah it's probably a good
idea do you don't say stuff like that
the president says yeah that's probably
a good idea you're the freaking
president they talk about being
presidential so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
you